[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'étude de l'uniforme de rigueur dans
les centres nucléaires le général de
Gaulle a commencé son 20e voyage en
France par Pierre latte et Cadarache qui
seront de mal et deux pièces maîtresses
de l'industrie atomique française il a
voulu également au cours de ce voyage
allait s'incliner sur ce plateau du
Vercors que la résistance des maquisards
en 1944 fit entrée dans l'histoire au
prix de 750 Martigues
[Musique]
Avignon Carpentras pendant les quatre
jours de ce voyage nombreux étaient les
Français qui avaient tenu à saluer à son
passage le président de la République
dans chacune de ces allocutions le chef
de l'État a développé sur tous les
raisons qui poussent la France à jouer
son rôle personnel au milieu des nations
et entre les deux colosses qui
détiennent la force les Français a-t-il
dit ont le droit de penser à être les
meilleurs juges de ce qu'ils ont à faire
et qu'ils n'ont à laisser à personne le
droit d'agir ou de parler pour eux
[Musique]
1500 ans d'histoire
nous ont appris qu'être la France
cela ne va pas sans difficulté
sans risque et sans frais mais
autant que jamais
nous tenons à l'indépendance
ouvert voici bientôt un an par Jean 23
le concile est humani du Vatican II a
repris ses travaux après 9 mois
d'interruption 9 mois au cours
desquelles le cardinal Montigny est
devenu le pape Paul VI autour du nouveau
souverain pontif voici de nouveau réunis
immense assemblée de l'église en ouvrant
solennellement cette deuxième session
Paul VI s'en a défini l'objet veillez au
renouveau de l'Église ouvrir le dialogue
avec les églises séparées jeter à un
pont vers le monde d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
chaque époque assez héros la nôtre à
Gagarine le premier homme qui est jamais
tourné dans l'espace autour de la Terre
est venu passer quelques jours à Paris
où la population lui a réservé un
accueil en enthousiaste il y a eu
d'autres cosmonautes mais Gagarine fut
le premier et son nom reste attaché au
début de l'ère cosmique c'est à ce titre
qu'il devait être la vedette au palais
de l'UNESCO du 24e congrès international
d'astronautique le 24e déjà ou 1000
spécialistes ont évoqué les nouvelles
étapes de la conquête de l'espace et
yuri Gagarine ajoutera à ses nombreux
trophées le prix galabert
d'astronautique pour son vol orbital
d'avril 61 il n'y a pas 3 ans
[Musique]
il se porte bien très bien même témoin
celui-ci qui chante avec le même succès
depuis quelques 30 ans
[Musique]
le temps des guitares
le temps des filles et de l'amour
vous l'avez reconnu c'est bien Tino
Rossi celui-là même un peu plus mince
sans doute qui chantait qatari
[Musique]
c'était l'époque du célèbre film nappe
au baiser de feu ou Tino Rossi tenait
déjà sous son charme tout un public
féminin un public où se retrouvait
toutes les classes et toutes les
générations et dont l'admiration émue
devait l'accompagner pendant un quart de
siècle quelle femme depuis cette époque
n'a pas frémit lorsque celle vais la
Vocalis célèbre
aujourd'hui dans sa villa d'Ajaccio Tino
Rossi entre son épouse et son fils peut
dire qu'il est au monde le chanteur dont
le plus grand nombre de disques à
reproduit la voix et qu'il est resté
pour le public une idole dans le
prestige est demeuré intact
c'est la raison pour laquelle les
visites sont nombreuses à la Villa Le
Scudo où se rencontrent aussi bien des
compositeurs de Paris que les
guitaristes de l'île de beauté et l'on
sait que la guitare a joué un certain
rôle dans la vie de Tino Rossi
[Musique]
28 ans après Marinella et Tino Rossi se
retrouve sur les planches à l'heure du
twist mais ce sera un twist de chats
depuis toujours
[Applaudissements]
en venant d'inaugurer la troisième
Biennale de Paris me tiendrait Malraux
ministre des Affaires Culturelles avait
rendez-vous avec ce que l'on pourrait
nommer la nouvelle vague de l'art un art
qui surprend sans doute mais qu'il
convient aussi de considérer d'un œil
neuf
[Musique]
plus de 1000 exposants de moins de 35
ans représentant 58 pays nous entraîne
ainsi de réalité nouvelle en réalité
nouvelle
du métro dévoreur d'homme au soufflet
qui permet d'apprécier dans les
conditions optimales l'oeuvre qu'il
anime
[Musique]
un regard sur l'anti machine la machine
parfaitement inutile et il ne sera plus
possible de nier l'existence d'un art
nouveau aux formes multiples suscité par
le rythme de plus en plus rapide de
notre époque rêvons
[Musique]
aussi Messieurs d'élégance fonctionne
pour les sportifs en effet l'élégance
doit être adapté et pratique et ce
costume à gilet sans manche fera le
bonheur des automobilistes une mode
créée par des sportifs pour des sportifs
tel est le mot d'ordre lancé par
l'association de propagande du vêtement
masculin devint un aréopage d'Ases du
volant et du ballon rond Louis Fineau
ancienne internationale de football a
même joué les mannequins quatre boutons
et petits revers pour la ville Bruno
bolini un autre international a fait ses
premiers pas sur le podium en présentant
sa veste à poche verticale
quant à Marcel qui fut capitaine de
l'équipe de France il a préféré la veste
classique mais comportant des coudes
renforcés de daim
mais on s'intéressera tout spécialement
au par-dessus cape conçu sans manche
pour laisser à l'automobiliste toutes
les anses du geste avec un souvenir ému
du temps des Fiat
[Musique]
une fois de plus l'équipe de France de
football maillot français culotte
blanche a manqué sa rentrée
internationale il est vrai qu'elle
rencontrait à Sofia en match aller des
quarts de finale de la Coupe d'Europe
des nations sa bête noire la Bulgarie
depuis les années les Bulgares se
dressent toujours avec succès sur le
chemin des Français
la tradition est encore respectée malgré
les prouesses du gardien de but Bernard
et les exploits techniques du capitaine
yvanouissent des balles qui auraient pu
faire mouche l'équipe de France en a eu
quelques-unes
comme celle-ci par exemple mais quand le
destin n'apporte pas son petit coup de
pouce à une équipe rien à faire pour
gagner
et les Bulgares ont encore battu la
France par un but à zéro c'est la
coutume mais la revanche à Paris c'est
aussi une coutume alors les Français
sont quand même optimistes
[Musique]